joining me now is congressman thomas
massey who serves on the house judiciary
committee with big hearings today
congressman which part of tonight's
speech did you find most offensive uh
basically all of it i mean the red flag
laws that's doing away with due process
in this country
but they say that if there's a flag on
someone for certain behaviors
once they show that they don't have
those behaviors the gun you can petition
to get your gun back you're laughing
yeah and that doesn't always happen you
don't get an attorney appointed to you
it's not like a real court and look
there's already laws in all 50 states
that would let you adjudicate this and
take away somebody's guns but those laws
involve
a mental health expert they involve
a lawyer for the person who's being
accused red flag laws turn that all
around and they end up with these you
know early morning raids on people
that uh are just going to be irritated
and frustrated and and there's no help
for them after they're they're harassed
there was another moment from tonight i
want to play watch
we should repeal the liability shield
that often protects gun manufacturers
from being sued for the death and
destruction caused by their weapons
they're the only industry in this
country that has that kind of immunity
that's fantastic has he missed the
pharmaceutical companies the vaccine
manufacturers or really the gun
manufacturers can be sued if their
product is effective product liability
right for product liability for
defective just like for a car but if
somebody misuses a car then the car
manufacturer is not you know oh they
want to shut down the gun companies like
they hurt tobacco right so it's the same
analogy that they use yeah and that
that's actually they know that was the
quickest way to put gun manufacturers
out of business is to open them up to
frivolous lawsuits this is about
politics he basically made the point
that if these things aren't done or at
least some of them aren't done then the
voters should take it out on you and
other republicans watch
i think we have the sound bite maybe we
don't but he basically said that you
know enough is enough to make this issue
central to your vote
yeah and you know we had a hearing today
that lasted 10 hours where the democrats
in the house are going to put a
smorgasbord of things that don't work in
front of senators in the senate and try
to get some of the weak need republicans
to bite on that but what was clear today
in our hearing and i think also in joe
biden's speech is that they're not
serious about ending school shootings
but they are serious about taking away
why do you say they're not serious about
ending school shootings because none of
their solutions would work if they
really were serious they would quit
advertising our kids as being in
gun-free zones the schools that have
gotten away from advertising that the
schools that have posted signs that said
our staff is armed and they're willing
to use force to stop somebody from
hurting our kids those schools have
never seen a mass body i think ramos
would have been stopped by that
um i think that these shooters go select
they they are they're evil but they're
not stupid and they are cowards but
they're trying to run up a body count
and if they know they're going to be
shot when they go in there they're not
going to try it one of the
the
issues that were discussed today the
possible measures anti-gun measures
would perhaps pass in the senate if you
had to predict right now the raising the
age for the ars maybe raising the age
not just for ars but any semi-automatic
uh shotgun or rifle that has the biggest
chance but the scariest one
that they proposed today was that the
you have to store your firearms in a way
that's federally approved and if you
don't they could come in and see so it
has to that could be a pretext for
taking your gun if your if your gun is
not stored in a way that we haven't
described yet right okay congressman
we'll be following this thanks for uh
joining us tonight thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else